[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Robin is
in Phoenix hi Robin welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thank you Jeremy for taking my call
sure I am going to retire in about three
years at 76. I have no mutual funds no
401K my question is should I buy or rent
at that time at 76.
okay
how would you be able to buy if you
don't have any money
yeah well I've got these I've got time
so currently my income is 4 500 a month
2K is going to rent
2K is going to student loans and five
and I spent 500 on
um daily on that living you know living
expenses you're 70 years old and you
have a student loan
yes
and I haven't paid it off yet but I will
pay it off it's expected to be paid off
in March of 24.
okay what's the balance on it
twelve thousand
so I'm paying two thousand a month on
that
2K 2K all right I'm really curious how
you end up with a student loan at your
age how did you do that
well let's call pain the interest I I
paid the interest only for a long time
so that's a long time
since 2020. since 2005 I guess
that's when I graduated you graduated in
in 05 so you graduated 20 years or 18
years ago
and you've been paying and your degree
is in what
that particular degree I've got some
more since that time but that particular
degree was in Communications
okay all right and what do you do for a
living
I'm a Quality Inspector okay
wow
all right
um
the the thing that runs through my head
is this I obviously you at retirement
have to have monthly money to pay uh an
electric bill and buy food
and provide shelter okay
the largest line item in your budget for
the rest of your life if you live to be
95 another 20 something years
is going to be
um housing
and if you're renting
your cost of housing is going to go up
every year because rent always goes up
that makes sense
if you buy
at least you're locked into what you're
going to be spending on housing from
this point forward
so buying is good having a paid off home
by the time you get there is even better
and of course having a nest egg to live
on so do you have
a pension in the background of this or
are you counting on just Social Security
to feed you
no
um I'll finish the rest um so right
currently what I have is a universal
life policy that has a cash value
approximately 9 000 in it I'm reluctant
to cash it out because it has a
long-term care writer of 50 months on it
at four percent so that's going to give
me uh 15 about 1500 a month just for
that now as I share
um at the End by the time I retire I
will have approximately five hundred
dollars in pension and 2500 I'm guessing
2500 in Social Security which gives me 3
000 and no money in savings
all right I want you to catch the
universal in and pay the student loan
down
and let's be done with the student loan
very quickly let's get that in the
background as soon as possible so we can
try to accomplish a couple of these
other goals which is housing and start
to build some kind of a nest egg over
the next three years so basically you're
going to live on beans and rice for the
next three years while you throw as much
money towards housing buying a home and
as much money towards a Mystic as you
can throw
and both of those are going to be better
moves than a bad Universal policy so
we've got to get the student loan in
your rearview mirror to pull that off
okay get the student loan in your
rearview mirror build an emergency fund
and then start saving for a down payment
while you're putting at least 15 percent
of your income or more into retirement
and I want you to save as much as you
can save for retirement while putting
down as much as you can put down on a
house and and when you do buy a home I
want you to buy a very modest a very
inexpensive property
I am more concerned that you have basic
shelter that is locked in on its monthly
cost than I am you having a home that
you are necessarily thrilled with
okay that makes sense yeah I want to
stabilize I'm trying to stabilize your
future that's what I'm that's my first
goal your luxury or your comfort are
secondary but stabilizing the shelter
aspects of your future next 20 years is
really what I gotta lean on and uh wow
wow well the good news is I think you
can actually make a pretty good dent in
36 months on this if you'll be very
focused
um
I think that might be one of the oldest
student loan debt callers I've had it's
it's mind-boggling I'm sitting there
listening to that and because we're
having the student loan live stream
tonight uh it's absolutely free
uh ramseysolutions.com 7 PM Central 8
Eastern it's important to point out that
she is and I don't throw this word
around lightly you know this Dave she's
a victim of this cultural
message that is said if you get a degree
you're going to get a raise and
sometimes that's true many times it's
not and she can't agree and degrees was
in in degrees Communications and I'm not
in Communications exactly she's in
quality assurance and so you've got to
be careful these degrees don't come with
jobs you still got to go out and find
them get them and perform them well and
I I'm not I'm not trying to be unkind
but there are so many people that still
believe uh you go through a layoff at 45
or at 50 and you go I gotta go get more
education maybe but probably not
probably not yeah not at the cost of
sitting at 70 years old still upstairs
no and see that's the exchange that
makes me so angry about
and let me just be honest let me be an
equal opportunity offender folks both
sides of the political aisle are in the
business of student loans it's big
business it's a lot of money and no
one's talking about legislation or
regulation to stop it to stop it and to
take on the unbelievable inflation this
is in the world of tuition doing a
service no
you people in government are not helping
that's right the population you are
harming the people that your car called
to govern it's a hidden text and and and
people are getting filthy stinking rich
off the backs of people like her and
it's really does need to stop
it really I mean seriously would
somebody grow a leadership backbone and
send it to Washington D.C